Hogwarts Legacy just confirmed new
gameplay details including a few that we
never expected in today's video I'll
break down my top 10 reveals from the
most recent gameplay showcase which
showed off the open world a more
detailed look at combat and a preview of
the room of requirement let's start off
with the brand new details on Broom
flight brooms will provide a quick way
to get around the open world outside of
Hogwarts as we ride there will be two
meters on the right side of the screen
the green being health and the yellow
being a boost meter according to game
director Alan 2 the higher you fly the
Broom the quicker this boost meter will
deplete of course because of the time
period we can't expect to ride anything
as Nimble and quick as Harry's Firebolt
for example in fact they've actually
Incorporated this into the story as
we'll be helping out a shopkeeper in
hogsmead who's trying to improve the
brooms they sell as we make upgrades our
broom will become faster and capable of
boosting even when we're higher in the
air we can also apply different cosmetic
changes to the broom through the same
shot it's also important to note that
the Cosmetics are purely that visual the
other upgrades will be handled
separately in addition to brooms we got
a more detailed look at how traversal on
a hippogriff or thestral works as well
the animal mounts will not have a boost
meter like the broom but can fly higher
right from the start without any penalty
they also have the advantage of quick
ground transportation in addition to
taking off for a quick flight around the
castle now it doesn't appear we'll be
able to cast spells while flying the
animal mounts or the broom however they
may still play a role in battle thanks
to a recent clip from the ccxp which
showed a grab horn trampling over some
goblins this showcase gave us an even
better look at the animations when we
summon these creatures from our
seemingly infinitely extendable bag that
would make Newt scamander proud the
animations have to be my favorite part
about all this rather than just having
these creatures fly beside us with a
whistle or some sort of spell we get
this incredibly slick animation that is
just perfect for this yet another small
way we're seeing Avalanche go above and
beyond to make this feel like an
authentic Wizarding World experience
when it comes to going above and beyond
though the room of requirement and
specific typically the customization
options have left many of us downright
stunned at all the options we have here
this is beautiful we never expected that
to be oh my God
gotta agree with my buddy Ben on that
one definitely one of those things we
were not expecting at all then you also
have this wonderful Conjuring effect
which looks like it came right out of
the movies now the dev team actually
refers to these as conjurations and they
also confirmed we'll be able to purchase
additional recipes for new furniture
from a shop called tomes and Scrolls
which is located in hogsmeade
additionally we'll unlock new objects by
engaging in different types of gameplay
throughout the world not only can you
conjure these items you can also scale
them larger or smaller and even change
the color the room of requirement is
also the area where we'll grow plants
and brew potions using these large
scientific tables which you guessed it
can also be customized one of the key
items located in the room of requirement
is this Enchanted Loom which is used to
upgrade gear and this brings us to yet
another big reveal from the Showcase and
that's the fact that we'll have three
different gear types legendary which is
orange extraordinary which is purple and
superb which is blue gear will
automatically include one primary
offense or defense stat but players can
use the loom home and magical materials
found throughout the world to add and
upgrade a secondary Stat or apply traits
to the Gear beasts can be rescued at
Beast dins whereas new trait recipes can
be collected in Bandit camps if you're
worried all these traits and gear will
mess with your ability to dress your
Witcher wizard in style Alan assures
players you can look like anything you
want whenever you want to you'll be able
to transmog gear so your preferred
traits and upgrades can apply to any of
your physical appearances now before
using the loom though you'll actually
need to conjure another item known as
the identification station this item is
used to identify new gear and reveal its
abilities so after that look at the
rumored requirement we were then traded
to a new look inside one of the game's
vivariums which is our area to care for
Magical beasts we've rescued from
poachers and if you thought we had a lot
of customization in the room of
requirement things open up even further
here systems designer McKenzie toner
referred to the conjuration items here
as ornaments many of them are purely
cosmetic but really help to create a
unique feel for the space that each
player will be able to make their own we
got a brief look at the potential here
with items like Stone archways ornate
benches and even feeders to speed up the
process of feeding the magical beasts to
keep them healthy and well fed oh and
there's also a toy box so you can play
fetch with the magical creatures now one
detail that was quickly skipped over in
the presentation but one that fans
absolutely caught right away is the
brief glimpse of a menu here that
reveals a braiding pin as one of the
options this will enable players to
conjure a pin that can be used to breed
two beasts and produce Offspring note
that the beasts we see throughout this
area all have an icon indicating whether
they are male or female yet another
gameplay mechanic here I don't think any
of us were expecting and it will be
fascinating to see just how deep this
mechanic goes how many different
creatures can we breed in here Community
manager Chandler wood even went as far
to say that what we saw in the Showcase
was only the tip of the iceberg for
everything you can do here so while I
know many weren't too happy about the
decisions to exclude quidditch and
minigames like Wizards chess for me at
least it's nice to see other mechanics
here like caring for magical creatures
and customizing our space in the room of
requirement as for some of the core
gameplay mechanics Alan mentioned there
are some items that are tied to the
game's day night cycle and while he
didn't explicitly confirm it I also
think this means it's likely we're
getting season specific and day night
specific quests as well in the first
part of the Showcase there were numerous
icons popping up around the world as the
player Flew Over the Hamlet surrounding
the castle missions that happen at
specific times of day certainly aren't
unique to Hogwarts Legacy and they've
been done in games before that being
said I'm so glad to see them here
because they always make the world feel
just a little bit more alive and a
little bit more believable as for the
seasons we also gotta look at what the
world outside Hogwarts looks like in the
snow and Alan even confirmed what's been
a big request from fans for quite some
time so there are moments like when it
reaches certain holidays or things like
that where hogs needs
holidays and the school reacts to
holidays and you see the decorations
around those environments change that
really helped just kind of make me feel
like I'm there one of the game's Biggest
Mysteries continues to be the ancient
magic in our character's connection to
it as far as The Story Goes we still
don't know much however we did learn
more in the Showcase about how this can
be used in battle as you chain combo
attacks against enemies and collect the
blue magical Aura Left Behind after some
fights you'll power up your ancient
magic meter once it reaches the halfway
point you'll be able to trigger an
incredibly powerful attack using L1 and
R1 in the Showcase we see this manifest
itself in three different attacks one
that has this sort of exploding effect
and we can kind of see some Sparks here
almost like a combustion and then
another one that just I don't even know
how you describe this just completely
makes the enemy disappears this sort of
black smokey effect and then one that
turns the enemy into a chicken according
to Alan the effect of this ancient magic
spell is actually dependent upon the
type of enemy we're fighting and the way
that manifests itself depends on the
type of enemy that you're fighting he
also confirmed the dash ability we
wondered about previously is an ancient
magic ability as well what he did not
confirm is what happens if we let the
meter fill all the way to the top is it
possible that would unlock the devastate
dating Lightning Spell we saw in a
previous trailer or maybe we just get
two of the ancient magic attacks that
we've already talked about they also
confirmed three battle arenas in the
game with two of them being available to
all players the dark arts battle arena
which they showed off in great detail
throughout the Showcase will only be
included in the deluxe and Collector's
Editions of the game or as an add-on
purchase for those who go with the
standard edition of the game Alan
mentioned these Arenas will pre-equip
players with certain spells so in the
case of the dark arts battle arena it's
all about the unforgivable curses now to
be clear anyone can unlock these curses
in the game whether you have the dark
arts pack or not but dark arts battle
arena will give you access to the
specific spells within the arena even if
you choose not to learn them in the main
game they also confirmed that you'll
earn different cosmetics by completing
the various battle arenas now as for the
three unforgivable spells we also
learned some key new details about them
first of which is the fact that they're
actually slottable spells and not simply
finisher spells that we had learned
about before also Avada Kedavra is true
to the series and completely takes out
enemies Wing cast does not matter even a
full-grown mountain troll gets taken
down with one shot now it does include a
longer cooldown meter to account for its
potency but what about the other
unforgivables well if you're curious
about those I have a full breakdown of
all three already posted here on the
channel so check out the video on the
right side of your screen now if you
want to learn just how devastating they
can be in Hogwarts Legacy as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon